[Musique]
on est dans le débat sur France 24
l'Italie bascule à droite et à l'extrême
droite l'alliance des droites obtient
44% des suffrages aux élections
législatives dont 26% pour Fratelli
ditalia une majorité nette donc à la
Chambre des députés et au Sénat pour la
coalition à gauche le patron du Parti
démocrate Enrico l'État a déploré un
jour triste pour l'Italie a-t-il dit et
il a annoncé qu'il abandonnait ses
fonctions lors du prochain congrès du
parti Giulia Meloni a reçu le soutien de
la Pologne de la Hongrie du parti
d'extrême droite espagnole Vox et du
rassemblement national en France
Emmanuel Macron respecte un choix
démocratique et appelle à continuer à
œuvrer ensemble alors comment expliquer
le score de l'alliance des droites qui
est Georgia Meloni une fasciste une
poste fasciste une conservatrice une
populiste l'Italie va-t-elle connaître
un recul des droits des femmes et des
minorités proches de Victor Hormann son
accession au pouvoir
un défi pour l'Europe et quelle sera
finalement la relation entre l'Italie et
la France et qu'elle sera même le
programme de la troisième puissance
économique du vieux continent pour en
parler j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés Béatrice Giblin bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue géographe professeur Émilie à
l'Institut français de géopolitique et
vous êtes également directrice de la
revue Hérodote excellente revue
d'ailleurs il faut le noter en face de
vous vous avez mis quel la Marzano
bonsoir vous êtes philosophe ancienne
député d'ailleurs du un parti
démocrate et auteur de mon nom et sans
mémoire on voit donc votre livre à
l'écran et c'est chez Stock bienvenue à
vous également avec nous également Carlo
Alberto Bruza bonsoir vous êtes avocat
président de l'association réaction 19
bienvenue à vous également nous avons en
Italie il est à Bologne John Luca
pasarelli bonsoir politologue et
professeur université de sapiensa de
Rome bonsoir à vous monsieur de votre
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
également vous pouvez bien sûr tous
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux c'est le
hashtag débat F24 et vous pouvez le
faire tout au long de l'émission ce
scrutin italien est donc une victoire
claire de droite de la droite et de
l'extrême droite l'abstention aussi lui
as-tu un record il faut le dire à 36%.
on va écouter quelques réactions
enfin nous avons du changement parce que
cela fait un certain nombre d'années en
Italie que nous n'en n'avons pas eu
enfin nous avons voté pour quelqu'un de
nouveau je n'ai pas voté pour elle parce
que je ne suis pas de droite mais je
pense que la politique du démocrate
l'État était vraiment mauvaise il
n'était pas la bonne personne je suis
désolé pour les Italiens qui ont voté
pour lui parce que c'était évident qu'il
allait perdre
je m'attends à plus de souveraineté pour
l'Italie maintenant dans les limites des
règles de l'Union européenne
je m'attends à ce que nous soyons plus
entendu au sein de l'UE
c'est la grande gagnante de ce scrutin
je suis une femme je suis une mère je
suis chrétienne à telle lancée à Rome en
2019 alors qui était celle qui a toutes
les chances de devenir la prochaine
présidente du Conseil italien on fait le
point en images
prononcez en 2019 ce fervent discours
défini giorgium et Loni elle met en
avant 7 devises
je suis Georgia je suis une femme je
suis une mère je suis italienne je suis
chrétienne des valeurs d'extrême droite
défendues depuis son adolescence à 15
ans Georgia Meloni intègre des
associations étudiantes postes fascistes
interrogés par France 3 elle assume son
admiration pour le douteché moi je crois
que moussolini c'était un bon production
c'est-à-dire qui est tout ce qu'il a
fait il a fait pour l'Italie son
ascension est fulgurante à 29 ans
Georgia Meloni devient la plus jeune
députée italienne à 31 ans la plus jeune
ministre Silvio Berlusconi lui confie le
portefeuille de la Jeunesse fin 2012
tournant stratégique
[Musique]
face aux dissensions qui ronge la droite
elle fondent un parti Fratelli d'Italia
frères d'Italie
Giorgia mélony a des racines dans
l'extrême droite et elle dirige en
partie qui il y a seulement quelques
années était très éloigné de l'idée de
diriger le pays et d'être le premier
parti aux élections
l'italienne suit une stratégie campée
dans l'opposition encore et toujours
même l'an dernier quand l'ancien
gouverneur de la Banque centrale
européenne forme un cabinet d'unité
nationale elle se revendique
anti-système anti-immigration anti LGBT
mais travail depuis plusieurs années
pour changer l'image de son parti
ils diront que nous sommes extrémistes
racistes fascistes homophobe et que nous
n'avons pas de dirigeants capables de
gouverner après les résultats au
législatives elle entre dans une autre
dimension lors de son discours de
remerciement celle qui est en passe de
devenir le nouveau visage de l'Italie
cherchait à envoyer un message d'unité
elle promet de gouverner pour tous les
Italiens
Mika Marzano je commence par vous parce
que vous étiez une ancienne députée du
Parti démocrate et vous la connaissez
Giorgia Meloni comment la classer vous
avez fasciste elle est néo fasciste non
allez poste fasciste comme on dit elle
est bref comment est-ce que vous
classifiez conservatrice ça c'est sûr
fasciste tout simplement vous dites
fasciste oui j'ai dit ça parce que post
fasciste je ne sais pas bien ce que
c'est comme terme bon désormais on
l'appelle comme ça mais je ne sais pas
exactement quelle est la signification
Neo fasciste oui on pourrait dire aussi
dans les sens où elle n'est pas fasciste
dans les sens classique ou historique du
terme mais ces racines elles sont bien
là elle vient de là il n'a jamais
condamné les fascisme historiques il a
toujours dit la droite à relégué dans
l'histoire les fascisme mais il n'a
jamais prononcé un mot pour qu'on puisse
comprendre exactement quelle est sa
position et puis et oui les xénophobes
il est homophobe il met en danger les
droits des femmes et les
vous qui êtes une spécialiste de
l'extrême droite oui ça chiche pas je
comprends très bien que vous puissiez la
qualifier comme ça mais par rapport à ce
qu'a été la période de Mussolini on
n'est pas dans les années 30 on est
effectivement en 2022 donc cette
équivalence si vous voulez oui elle est
fasciste moi je qualifierais plutôt de
conservatrices radicale populiste
maintenant je pense que le terme de
fasciste il faut le réserver à ce qui a
été la période mussolinienne si vous
voulez c'est comme si on allait
qualifier tout de suite de nazi un
mouvement d'extrême droite en Allemagne
les situations ne sont pas ne sont pas
les mêmes donc je pense que c'est plus
prudent même si je comprends très bien
que vous puissiez la qualifier comme tel
moi d'un point de vue plus extérieur que
le vôtre et analysant les mouvements
d'extrême droite en Europe
je nuancerais en disant donc une droite
radicale absolument très conservatrice
réactionnaire sur le plan de la société
stable mais je la qualifierai néanmoins
pas de fasciste rien ne nous dit qu'elle
ne respectera pas à la limite les règles
de la démocratie on ne le sait pas alors
on ne le sait pas ne les respectez pas
donc c'est à ce titre là que je ferai
des nuances
Carlo Alberto Bruza vous faites des
nuances aussi alors il faut savoir que
c'est au Berlusconi parce que vous vous
êtes plutôt proche du parcours
je mépris la carte postale par contre je
suis choqué d'entendre de tes injures je
suis choqué d'une femme pour une femme
parce que aujourd'hui
vous avez fait passer une interview
d'une gamine bien sûr
c'est même un joyeux c'est même
diffamatoires strictement juridique
premièrement deuxièmement aujourd'hui il
faut absolument être pour LGBT promo
pour que on soit dans une doxa moi je ne
sais même pas je n'ai jamais entendu et
je vous mets au défi de voir dans le
programme qu'elle est contre le GBT
contre les gens elle dit simplement
attendez je suis une femme et ça je
trouve déjà c'est exceptionnel dans un
pays de misogyne comme l'Italie qui
aujourd'hui il y a une femme qui sera
peut-être ministre de cela aider
manifestement
écoutez à l'Italie on a jamais vu une
femme exercée la fonction de président
du conseil mais j'essaierai je suis bien
heureux d'avoir enfin une femme et voir
ce qu'une femme pourra faire dans un
pays de misogyne et d'hommes ratés
un jour Michael
vous pouvez répondre oui oui j'y réponds
mais bon vous avez et j'aime pas non
plus les tons exagiter
pas agitée
un jour j'attends encore avec espoir
qu'elle se prononce à propos de ce qui a
été les fascisme j'attends encore qu'il
dit comme les présidents Sergio matériel
là qu'elle est fascisme a été les mal
absolu et qu'elle est fascisme a
contribué à la choix quand elle aura dit
ça j'essaierai complètement rassuré John
Lucas vaarelli vous pouvez réagir vous
qui êtes politologue vous êtes avec nous
à Bologne alors fasciste ou pas fasciste
ou conservatrice
comme comment dirait les général de
Gaulle vaste programme je pense qui si
on approche
les sujets comme ça on arrive pas loin
je pense qu'il George a Meloni au delà
des
définitions n'a pas vraiment réformer
les parties donc c'est il est c'est
conduit sur une posture irlandais de la
droite radicale et je pense qui je suis
pas d'accord avec
les monsieur qui a parlé tout à l'heure
j'ai pas bien entendu son homme je
m'excuse
les fascisme c'est pas une opinion les
fascisme c'est un crime comme il disait
les présidents de la République
italienne
Sandro Pertini donc je pense qu'il si on
reste sur la question qui George Meloni
c'est pas fasciste elle-même c'est pas
un risque elle ne représente pas à
risque pour la démocratie mais elle est
représentent avec son agent agenda
politique un risque pour une Union
européenne et il a été très clair très
franche en parlant des la dissolution de
l'Union européenne et n'a jamais dit que
en faveur de l'Union européenne elle a
dit qu'il y a en faveur de de l'Europe
c'est à dire
du conseil de la subsidiarité c'est à
dire je suis avec l'OTAN avec
l'attentisme mais quelle atlantisme
l'atlantisme des Donald Trump
vous pourrez plutôt Trump piste à vous
entendre on va on va revenir sur
l'Europe avant ça une question tout de
même sur la gauche je voudrais vous
poser Mickael amarzano parce que vous
connaissez bien cette cette partie de
l'Italienne récolta qui a pas réussi à
mettre en place cette coalition avec le
mouvement 5 étoiles est-ce qu'il a fait
des erreurs il a reconnu maintenant il
va il va effectivement démissionner de
ses fonctions pourquoi est-ce que la
gauche finalement en termes de en termes
de suffrage ce n'est pas mal mais comme
il y avait pas de coalition elle a
vraiment tout perdu oui je ne fais pas
dire que la campagne électorale de la
bouche a été réussie au contraire j'ai
même tendance à dire que tout a été mal
fait et là ça parce qu'après les
problèmes c'est que on va se retrouver
pendant cinq ans avec des grosses
difficultés mais c'est vrai que il
rigoletta aurait dû essayer de tout
faire pour construire constituer un fond
républicain c'est-à-dire en fait toute
la différence qu'il y a entre ce qui
s'est passé en France face à Marine Le
Pen et ce qui s'est passé en Italie face
à Giorgia miloni c'est que d'une part
ici il y a conscience dans certaines
dangers au moins on a une certaine idée
de ce que les pays veut devenir et du
coup on essaie de mettre entre
parenthèses et les différences là où en
Italie en dépit des problèmes face
auxquels on se on n'a pas eu les courage
ou la force de créer une ration
rassemblement
courageux ne rigoletta c'est pas arrivé
à faire ce qu'il aurait dit et puis
l'autre chose si vous me permettez c'est
que la gauche aussi à plomb de
responsabilités dans les filles de ne
plus être capable vraiment de parler aux
électeurs parce qu'il y a ça aussi quand
on laisse les gens dans des situations
des grandes difficultés quand on prend
pas en charge
les problèmes liés au travail et
rigoletta il a battu sa campagne autour
des trois mots qui sont très importants
c'est-à-dire l'environnement bien sûr il
y a les problèmes de l'environnement il
faut s'en occuper la question des droits
bien sûr il y a les droits civils et les
droits sociaux et puis la question
effectivement des lentilles fascisme
mais après il faut remplir des contenus
Citroën
suffisamment en tout cas Béatrice que
c'est un petit peu ce que le même
problématique qu'on retrouve à gauche
ailleurs en Europe mais là il y avait
quand même une particularité si vous
laissez que Enrico aurait dû à ce
moment-là s'associer avec compter qui
représentait le mouvement 5 étoiles qui
était celui qui avait fait tomber Mario
Draghi alors c'était quand même un peu
de compliqué parce que faire l'alliance
avec quelqu'un qui a fait tomber le
parti le gouvernement qu'on soutenait ou
ça devient là un peu de l'équilibrisme
politique difficile mais du coup il ne
peut pas être très cher alors il le paye
très cher mais je pense que pour lui ça
aurait été une sorte de trahison si vous
voulez vis-à-vis de draguer et vis-à-vis
on va dire du centre gauche globalement
dans une alliance avec le mouvement 5
étoiles je suis d'accord il le paye très
cher dans le cadre de la gauche
européenne il faut tenir compte quand
même du système électoral dans lequel on
est est-ce que c'est une chose de faire
44% des voix et elle a une majorité ils
ont dans cette alliance parce que c'est
pas effectivement Fratelli Italia qui
est majoritaire il faut absolument
qu'elle a absolument besoin de
silverlusconi et elle a absolument
besoin aussi de la Ligue donc de
formation
non justement et en plus on risque
d'avoir peut-être un Salvini qui va pas
rester à la tête de la Ligue parce qu'il
fait des scores tellement mauvais y
compris en Vénitie ce qui est quand même
absolument étonnant au dernier régional
sont partis faisait plus de 60 % des
voix et là il fait 15% des voix en
Vénitie c'est absolument pas il a été
désavoué à ce point Salvini mais parce
que je pense que la dans le cadre de la
Vénétie je pense que c'est quand même un
électorat d'extrême droite et comme pour
le Canada Dry on préfère l'original à la
copie et d'une certaine façon bah ils
ont voté à ce moment-là Fratelli
d'Italia c'est parce que c'est quand
même je crois dans le cadre de la
Vénétie je tiens pas un discours général
là qui est tout à fait tout à fait
important mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même de regarder cette
géographie électorale et là on va
retrouver des choses similaires à la à
ce qu'on connaît que la gauche est pas
su répondre véritablement aux aux
difficultés de vie des classes on va
dire les plus populaires les plus
défavorisées c'est la même chose dans le
cadre de par exemple tout à fait tout à
fait similaire bien sûr mais alors que
c'était pas tout à fait la même chose en
cas de l'Allemagne ça sera intéressant à
voir et c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose en cas de l'espace mais sont aussi
des configurations qu'en Espagne il y a
pas des mots aussi que la partie
il est passé pas l'équivalent de les
filles aujourd'hui ça Carlo Alberto
bruzzaville connaissez bien la droite
ils vont arriver à s'entendre Salvini
Silvio Berlusconi qu'il a mis en avant
on a vu dans le sujet que ça a été le
premier s'il veut bien luconi à lui
mettre le pied à l'étrier à Giorgio
Meloni est-ce qu'ils vont parvenir à
s'entendre
c'est une chance extraordinaire d'avoir
rattaché le chariot de mélodie par
contre subsister politique absolument
parce qu'on a vu quand même que les
derniers temps c'est le français plutôt
une force qui s'est accrochée à d'autres
le prix de wagons et il a soutenu
draguer quand même avec force on a vu
draguer c'était quand même merveille et
ensuite le le lessivage mais moi je
partage pour le point de vue par rapport
à la Ligue et le gros souci ça sert à le
changement de leadership de la Ligue qui
va peut-être générer un trouble et là la
majorité on l'a si on l'a ils l'ont si
effectivement les trois forces sont unis
mais sans la Ligue du Nord le problème
existe et là tout dépendant si c'est
celui qui maintiendra la leadership ou
s'il va être remplacé et là je me dis
autre chose
c'est du possible c'est du possible mais
c'est une possibilité parce que en
réalité Salvin les dernières les
derniers deux années à flotter beaucoup
il a pas su garder une ligne et ses
lignes les gens de la Ligue l'ont
toujours voulu et là et les gens du Nord
ont pris l'attitude de Salvini comme une
trahison de France
avec avec l'État et bien là aussi ils
ont cette raison parce que réalité le
fait de ne pas avoir défendu les
principes fondateurs de la Ligue qui
sont défendus par les gouverneurs parce
que on a quand même des choses qui vont
pas oublier beaucoup de villes on a
beaucoup de gens sont dirigés par la
Ligue c'est-à-dire que c'est une force
ancrée sur un plan administratif
la fin finalement de Matteo Salvini
c'est un peu ce que montre aussi ce
scrutin dont on a c'est une star de la
Ligue il y a quelques années si on peut
dire on l'a vraiment connu en Europe
d'ailleurs dans ces affrontements on va
revenir avec la France et maintenant ça
serait terminé pour lui
c'est facile à dire mais il y a pas de
challenger pour Salvini parce que
d'ailleurs les présidents de vento il y
a un problème il est from verte et
historiquement la Liga a été
gouvernement pour pour des gens qui
viennent des des Milan de la région de
Milan donc c'est aussi un problème
des dirigeants et en plus Salvini
vraiment il connaît les parties il
connaît les militants et comme vous les
voyez dans les symboles il y a son nom
donc c'est vraiment pendant les derniers
cinq années il a été les leaders du
parti donc c'est difficile à changer les
idées d'air sans sans
accord en plus il ne peut pas être
ministre parce qu'il y a un procès en
Sicile donc c'est difficile qui
peut-être nommé comme ministre
en plus c'est vrai qui la Ligue pourrait
être se radicalisée pour regagner ça
identité électorale pour gagner parce
que sont les comme
on le disait tout à l'heure ces
résultats c'est le pire depuis 92
ça pourrait poser problème vraiment dans
cette alliance on va début on va écouter
un extrait du tout premier discours d'un
des tout premier discours depuis
justement sa victoire de Giorgio Meloni
c'était hier soir à 2h30 du matin on
l'écoute
[Applaudissements]
nous le ferons dans le but d'unir les
gens de mettre en valeur ce qui les unit
plutôt que ce qu'il est divise mais que
la mort d'Anna alors ça c'est son son
discours de victoire elle veut
rassembler vous y croyez moyennement
vous disiez vous dites dans votre livre
d'ailleurs que l'Italie n'a pas fait son
travail de mémoire sur la Shoah par
exemple comme en France ça vous inquiète
mais moi j'y suis très enfin moi
j'hésite désespéré à employé en termes
qui est fort mais qui je pense les seuls
que je puisse employer parce que non
elle va pas rassembler l'italier ça va
devenir extrêmement compliqué ça va être
très dur pour beaucoup d'italiennes et
d'Italiens ça va être compliqué pour les
femmes qui vont pas pouvoir avoir accès
à plein de droits ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour les couples
gay et lesbienne il faut rappeler que
les responsables de la culture des
frères d'Italie des fatalité
les couples homosexuels n'y sont pas les
n'y sont pas légaux c'est-à-dire on est
dans un climat extrêmement dur et puis
il ne faut pas oublier non plus sur quoi
il a bâti sa campagne électorale enfin
et la prononcé des discours qui sont
vraiment choquants quand elle a défini
comme déviant tous ceux qui ne suivent
pas une certaine nombre des normes il a
dit qu'il a des violences il est
inscrite chez C et celle qui souffrent
des troubles du comportement alimentaire
il a invité la jeunesse assez régénérer
alors je vais bien qu'on parle par des
fascisme mais qui parlaient d'hommes
nouveau c'était justement les messages
du fascisme et c'est pour ça que si vous
me permettez juste deux secondes
dans les livres que je viens de publier
j'ai raconté l'histoire de ma famille
parce que je viens de découvrir que mon
grand-père a été un fasciste de la
première heure c'est à dire j'ai raconté
l'histoire de beaucoup de familles
italiennes
moi j'ai fait partie de la troisième
génération c'est à dire tous ceux et
celles dont les parents n'ont pas abordé
cet homme parce qu'il y avait quelque
chose à cacher les thèmes du fascisme
est très chaud en Italie parce que
l'Italie a différence de la France qui a
fait les comptes avec son passé il ne
faut pas oublier Chirac ce qu'il a dit
la France a une responsabilité dans la
Shoah et bien en Italie tout ça n'a pas
eu lieu nous avons eu en 2018 les
présidents matériels qui a reconnu ça
mais tout ça n'a pas n'est pas passé
c'est-à-dire dans les familles il y a
des secrets il y a des mensonges il y a
du refoulé il faudra aller plus loin
dans la reconnaissance de la part de
l'État italien de ce qui s'est passé des
gens mais important aussi des gens de
gauche parce que jusque là moi j'étais
de gauche j'ai pensé qu'elle est
fascisme était ailleurs et donc il faut
vraiment ouvrir chez soi et passer par
tous ce qui n'a pas été dit jusque-là
parce que sinon on bougera pas
en soit bien sûr
les historiens ont fait le travail les
historiens les universitaires italiennes
travaillent mais c'est les élites après
c'est des élites mais en France aussi ça
a été fait d'abord par les élites même
été au départ fait par un historien
américain donc c'est pas les Français
d'entrée de jeu qui se sont intéressés à
Vichy mais ce qui me semble tout à fait
important aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement les positions parce que
c'est ce qui va se passer maintenant qui
est important sur la société
particulièrement qui va y avoir un recul
de droit des femmes un recul des droits
des minorité avec justement Georgia en
tout cas sur l'avortement par exemple
non
mais je pense que entre ce qu'on dit
dans une campagne électorale et puis ce
qu'on fait quand on est au pouvoir dans
des rapports de force un peu compliqué à
gérer et ce sera compliqué à gérer parce
que il y aura le problème de la Ligue il
y aura même un problème avec François
italien sera pas comme ça et ça ira pas
tout droit donc
de fraternité elle est beaucoup plus
nuancée dans sa propre
il faut faire vraiment la différence
entre le discours de conquête et après
ça ce qu'on a pratique du pouvoir la
pratique du pouvoir j'ai juste prendre
un autre exemple celui sur l'économie il
y a quand même les prêtres 200 milliards
pour avoir donc à partir de ce moment-là
on peut pas on a des engagements parce
que c'est si l'Italie a été j'allais
dire aussi bien servi c'est parce que
c'était dragué et que draguer était
l'homme qui avait sauvé l'euro et que
draguer on lui faisait confiance et ben
alors si tu le dis Mario ok ça va mais à
partir du moment où c'est plus draguer
le rapport est change et on va être
extrêmement vigilant donc à mon sens la
marge de manœuvre sur ce terrain de
Georgia mélodie n'est pas si grande que
ça parce que les Italiens n'accepterait
pas de ne pas toucher l'argent qui est
attendu donc moi je suis plus prudente
si vous voulez vous attendez de voir oui
j'attends de voir Carlo Alberto brosas
sur cette question sociétale tout le
même elle est conservatrice très
clairement toutes ces positions l'ont
montrées
Nathalie elle est contre l'avortement
très clairement seulement elle est pour
rallonger le congé parental et elle est
pour aider les femmes seules et créer
des crèches voilà il y a une véritable
pourquoi ça parce qu'elle préfère des
Italiens à des étrangers il faut être
très clair si on fait plus d'Italiens et
ben on aura moins besoin d'étrangers
derrière ça enfin que moi je le lis ça
me semble être sa lecture des choses les
femmes elles font pas seulement des
enfants parce que il y a des crèches
Carlo Alberto brossa il y aura un recul
pour le drogue parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
a une représente que 26% même s'il a la
majorité il y a quand même aujourd'hui
un ancrage très fort moi je je trouve
qu'il faut donner une chance à une femme
et je trouve qu'il y a une opposition
forte en Italie construite de 75% des
gens qui n'ont pas voté mais aussi c'est
ce que voter donc il faut être confiant
parce que l'Italie est un pays qui a des
valeurs une histoire je suis je suis
d'accord sur ce que vous dites la
question de la même maison sur le
fascisme est une nécessité impérieuse
mon père a 12 ans monter les munitions
dans la Résistance et moi je sais je
suis tout je me suis toujours battu
contre celles et ceux qui ont régné que
le fascisme a été solidaire avec le
choix en France on aurait du mal
qu'aujourd'hui des gens du mal à
reconnaître que donc le problème mais je
pense que c'est faire fausse route ça
c'est un travail beaucoup plus global de
société où les philosophes de porter le
concours aujourd'hui n'a pas parlé d'une
révolution elle donne seulement une
approche conservateur je termine
conservateur je suis d'accord mais
aujourd'hui il y a assez de gens
cultivés révoluent construit pour porter
une opposition forte et une opposition
pourra même descendre dans la rue si
elle devait dépasser les bornes une
phrase juste parce que elle vient de
déclarer qu'il a Constitution italienne
c'est une belle constitution mais là
quand même 70 ans oui mais elle ne peut
pas la changer mais ce qu'il faut deux
tiers
des appâts donc voilà
la fin des résultats parce que des
résultats vous savez comme moi que on
choisit à
c'est lui le premier à avoir envoyé un
message de félicitation à Giorgia Méloni
Victor hurban attendait une bascule
politique de l'Italie depuis longtemps
précurseur selon lui d'une bascule
européenne je me réjouis de notre futur
coopération pour préserver la paix dans
nos pays et en Europe relancer
l'économie européenne et atténuer la
crise énergétique
après la Hongrie la Pologne et la Suède
l'extrême droite c'est donc emparé de
l'Italie la leader du parti Fratelli
d'Italia a donc aussi été félicité par
la formation polonaise droit et justice
les deux parties sont réunis au sein du
même groupe politique au Parlement
européen les conservateurs et
réformistes européens en France Marine
Le Pen s'est-elle aussi distinguée en
saluant la victoire du parti post
fasciste bravo à Georgia Meloni et
Matteo Salvini pour avoir résisté aux
menaces d'une Union européenne
anti-démocratique et arrogante mais le
son de cloche est radicalement différent
à l'Élysée sans trop se mouiller la
présidence de la République dirait
respecter le choix démocratique des
Italiens de son côté Matignon se montre
circonspect on sera attentif à ce que
ces valeurs sur les droits de l'homme
sur le respect des autres notamment le
respect du droit à l'avortement par
exemple soit respecté par tous pas de
félicitations non plus de la part de la
Commission européenne nous espérons que
nous aurons une coopération constructive
avec les nouvelles autorités italiennes
finalement la seule vraie pique va venir
de l'Espagne du ministre socialiste des
Affaires étrangères dans les moments
d'incertitude les populistes gagnent
toujours en importance et ils finissent
toujours de la même manière en
catastrophe leur réponse est toujours la
même fermons-nous sur nous-mêmes et
revenons au passé la dernière fois qu'un
parti d'extrême droite était à la tête
de l'Italie c'était en 1945 son chef
était Mussolini depuis le pays a
participé à toutes les étapes de la
construction européenne une Europe qui
n'est plus tout à fait la même ce lundi
la direction était Rome on retrouve
notre envoyé spécial Caroline de Camaret
Caroline est-ce qu'elle veut
s'affranchir des règles européennes
comme a pu le faire ou le fait encore
toujours Victor Hormann
c'est la question qui a été posée depuis
des semaines en fait même la présidente
de la Commission européenne
Ursula vanderleyen a osé dire que si
elle s'en a franchissait en tout cas des
valeurs de l'Union européenne et des
droits de l'homme et bien elle
utiliserait les instruments nécessaires
ce qui a déclenché lire de d'un Salvini
qui a dit que elle devait présenter des
excuses donc on est quand même dans un
rapport d'ores et déjà très tendu en
particulier avec les autres partenaires
de coalition ce qu'il y a quand même
assez frappant c'est que finalement elle
est alliée aussi de l'autre côté avec un
parti qui se dit de centre droit donc le
parti de Silvio berluscona Berlusconi
Forza Italia qui appartient au grand PPE
qui est dominant en Europe ce PPE et
bien il est allé même soutenir Manfred
Weber le grand chef du PPE est allé
soutenir Forza Italia ici même en Italie
dans la campagne il y a été reproché
d'ailleurs de soutenir un parti qui
avait et bien pas fait de cordon
sanitaires avec l'extrême droite c'est
quand même un exemple un exemple de
cette absence de cordon sanitaire qui
porte au pouvoir un parti post fasciste
au plus haut niveau d'ailleurs parce
qu'avant il y a eu des expériences vous
l'avez dit mais ça n'était pas à la
direction en tout cas la figure de
tutelle du chef de gouvernement donc ce
qu'il y a de vraiment intéressant c'est
que elle-même Georgia Meloni elle
appartient elle est vice-présidente au
niveau européen des conservateurs et
réformistes c'est-à-dire un parti où
figure les Polonais du Droit et Justice
des
ultrasons qui donnent du fil à retordre
à l'Union européenne elle se sent aussi
peut-être un peu proches de Victor Orban
en tout cas il l'a félicité et elle est
soi-disant Marine Le Pen est aussi très
contente de son élection là par contre
elle en est beaucoup moins proche en
effet elle a elle n'a pas soutenue
Marine Le Pen aux dernières élections
mais Éric Zemmour déjà et puis d'un
l'autre côté Georgia Molini finalement
elle n'appartient pas au même groupe que
Marine Le Pen c'est Monsieur Salvini qui
appartient à identité et démocratie donc
il y a aussi une rivalité entre divers
partis d'extrême droite mais ce qui a
quand même assez facilement dans notre
Union européenne on dit pas pas de
démocratie pour les ennemis de la
démocratie ben si en fait dans notre
Union européenne il y a de la démocratie
pour les ennemis de la démocratie parce
que
ceux-là ont constitué des groupes au
Parlement européen qui leur a donné des
vrais tribunes des vrais financements et
ils en ont profité pour taper sur
l'Union européenne vraiment à bras
raccourci mais depuis le brexit plus
aucun d'entre eux ne souhaitent little
exit ou sortir de l'Union européenne ou
encore moins sortir de l'euro parce
qu'ils se sont bien rendus compte que
financièrement ça n'est pas très
intéressant mais en attendant il
continue à avoir cette prose très anti
establissement européen anti
technocratie européenne et elle a
beaucoup surfé là-dessus et notamment
contre son adversaire
qui était le patron du Parti démocrate
et qui a dû rajouter l'éponge ce soir
Michela Marzano justement est-ce qu'on
va se retrouver dans une partie de bras
de fer entre justement cette nouvelle
majorité mais qu'elle a pardon Georgia
Georgia
Meloni je vais y arriver et
Bruxelles comme on a pu le voir avec
Orban comme on le voit avec les Polonais
par exemple dont elle est proche alors
moi j'y pense que ça va dépendre aussi
des thèmes c'est-à-dire moi je suis
d'accord que en ce qui concerne les
questions économiques je pense qu'elle
va se tenir au carreau et là l'Italie a
besoin de cet argent donc les plans des
relances c'est quelque chose bon elle va
peut-être essayer de toucher quelque
chose mais pas trop oui mais en échange
l'Europe enfin à Bruxelles on va le dire
de faire des réformes non non mais
baisser mais enfin pour moi les vrais
problèmes c'est les deux mots qui ont
été dit tout à l'heure valeur et droits
de l'homme parce que c'est sur ces
points là qu'il est très proches de la
polonais elle est très proche Jordan
c'est à dire de tout cette partie là de
l'Europe qui est en train de vouloir
revenir en arrière ils sont sortis de
l'État droit aussi donc est-ce que
l'Italie pourrait aller aussi loin à
votre avis Béatrice Giblin je crois pas
je crois pas qu'il est rose séparation
des pouvoirs
Bluetooth Droit Justice et les coups de
boutoirs mais
ils vont quand même pas trop trop loin
non plus parce que il faut pas dire que
l'Europe ne réagit pas du tout par
exemple les aides à avoir après le 110
bon et les suspendent non mais on va
toujours très fort dans le discours puis
pour finir je vais prendre juste
l'exemple des immigrés en Pologne quand
même une remise en question
aussi forte de la population mais dans
la rue il y a des changements seulement
dans des partis politiques résultat il y
a eu quand même des juges qui ont pris
la mesure des enjeux et qui ont dit
attention attention les choses ne sont
pas linéaires et aussi simples que cela
je vous prends juste l'exemple d'orbane
qui hurlait contre les immigrants et
puis qui pour finir en catimini c'était
au moment de 2015 a ouvert la porte à un
certain nombre d'immigrés qu'il a quand
même bien pris très discrètement dont on
n'a pas parlé pour éviter que ça fasse
trop de bruit en tout cas ce week-end
Bruxelles enfin justement
Ursule
ils allaient menacer un certain nombre
d'aides à la Hongrie si elle ne
justement
Alberto Bosa on va se retrouver en
rapport de force également avec l'Italie
entre l'Italie au sel c'est une
certitude parce que les gens qui ont
voté mais non les nouveautés aussi pour
le message très fort contre l'Europe
parce que l'Europe c'est les pales robes
des peuples les peuples si on devait
faire un sondage aujourd'hui n'aime pas
cette Europe cette Europe elle sait
griller avec le titre sanitaire mais
l'Italie a vécu des principes de
problématiques aux yeux du soleil comme
les aquariums de la France pendant la
crise sanitaire je vous dis simplement
Dragui faisait des décrets qui durait 19
jours pour éviter même que le 20e jour
on puisse des attaquer devant le Conseil
d'État c'est tout simplement que la
crise sanitaire a donné une gifle au
doigt de l'homme à donner une gifle à
tout le droit fondamentaux y compris
l'Italie n'oublions pas que le soupe
Agrippa a fait que en Italie pendant la
phase de la crise sanitaire si tu
n'avais pas le sous-marie pas se
préparer acheter une paire de
chaussettes et ça on l'a pas fait si
vous pouvez comparer ça et puis ce qui
se passe par exemple en Hongrie et un
sur les justement
pendant la crise sanitaire
catastrophique en état de droit qui
était bafoué complètement je vous le dis
John Lucas et vous pouvez peut-être
réagir là-dessus on va se retrouver dans
un bras de fer là avec Mélanie
pourquoi j'étais invité parce que ça
fait une demi-heure et j'ai eu pas la
possibilité de parler je pensais que
vous étiez là que dans l'appart première
partie de l'émission donc c'est un peu
de ma faute
je vous aime mais vous êtes toujours là
donc allez-y alors
c'est facile à utiliser des clichés mais
je n'ai pas utilisé des clichés
politiques peuvent parce que là je suis
pas un politicien en militant je suis un
professeur je vais faire des raisons si
vous voulez un peu plus
sophistiqué
on a plus beaucoup de temps alors il va
falloir être concis s'il vous plaît
un groupe des gens qui font des trucs
sophistiqués c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
ça alors l'Italie c'est pas l'anglais
non plus donc c'est pas qui arrive
Meloni et fait la fin de la démocratie
la démocratie italienne elle est forte
et les stables il y a 10 citations très
fortes la présidence de la République il
y a un système c'est pas qu'il est c'est
pas le premier ministre de hier il
s'appelle président du Conseil des
ministres c'est pas une question de non
c'est une question soustentive ça veut
dire que le Président il a besoin de
négocier avec
plusieurs d'acteurs d'abord en plus il y
a à l'heure et l'Union européenne c'est
vrai qu'il melonie comme elle était dit
n'a pas fait des réformes qui ont
commencé en 95 par Jean francofini qu'il
était très proche des Nicolas Sarkozy il
a dit les fascisme a été les mal absolu
c'est vrai qui m'élonie n'a jamais dit
ça c'est vrai qu'il dit Dieu patrouille
famille voilà mais je je pense qu'il
faut observer
les premiers pas notamment au niveau
diplomatique je pense et je m'arrête là
qui m'élonie n'irait pas comme première
voyage ni à Berlin ni à Paris et
peut-être j'espère pas Washington parce
que ce sera un problème pour l'Europe
j'espère qu'il aidera à Bruxelles donc
il faut voir l'Italie comme une
démocratie stable on n'est pas la
démocratie des bananes et donc
et qui arrive melonien va détruire le
système
c'est un peu plus compliqué qu'un cliché
facile à dire l'Italie c'est les malades
d'Europe juste si vous voulez je vous
dis que j'ai pas voté Meloni et je suis
de l'autre côté ma sœur ça ça n'ajoute
rien vous croyez en la force de la
démocratie italienne c'est ce que vous
nous dites
qu'il y a les les dangers Mélanie
c'est un père un discours très franc qui
n'a rien à la compréhension de phénomène
et comme si pendant 20 ans il y a
berlusconibles voilà et alors on
comprend rien c'est c'est pas qu'il est
mélonie va changer les droits de l'homme
c'est pas elle c'est elle Caroline
Caroline
les membres de la Cour constitutionnelle
on est bien d'accord donc elle peut
avoir un impact institutionnel il nous
reste deux minutes juste un point de
conclusion je voudrais parler de
l'Ukraine pardonnez-moi bien parler de
l'Ukraine Caroline rapidement on parle
justement est-ce qu'elle doit aller à
Bruxelles à Berlin voir ses partenaires
européens en France peut-être à Paris ça
serait quand même pas mal est-ce qu'elle
doit aller à Kiev est-ce
qu'effectivement la politique italienne
va rester donc dans la veine de celle de
Mario Draghi qui vraiment a toujours
soutenu Kiev depuis le début de manière
très claire
elle va peut-être changer d'avis mais
elle a pour l'instant tique son premier
voyage serait pour le Royaume-Uni alors
c'est un choix assez étonnant quand même
d'abord elle explique par l'idée que
elle continue à soutenir l'OTAN et
qu'elle continue à soutenir les crèmes
mais quand même rappelons que le
Royaume-Uni c'est le pays qui a brexité
youpi de l'Union européenne alors c'est
vrai que la question de son rapport à la
démocratie se pose elle se pose
d'ailleurs elle est très très fanatique
des États-Unis elle le dit je suis
atlantiste mais elle est Atlantis façon
Donald Trump et surtout façon Steve
Bannon qu'il a beaucoup conseillé elle
est devenue d'ailleurs cette twitteuse
qui a un rapport très éloigné avec la
vérité qui est capable de mettre en
avant des incidents terribles par
exemple elle a justement mis en scène
sur son Twitter le viol d'une femme
ukrainienne par des migrants pour
démontrer la nocivité des migrations
contre contre ça contre sa volonté et ça
c'est ça c'est aussi ça son rapport à la
vérité pour ce qui est de l'Ukraine elle
a deux partenaires de Co qui sont
effectivement pas très pas très
impatients de renouveler les sanctions
contre l'Ukraine Silvio Berlusconi qui a
reçu la résidence privée Vladimir
Poutine quand il était président du
conseil et en l'occurrence évidemment
matteocialvini qui considère que c'est
un homme d'État très intéressant le plus
intéressant du siècle donc ça
effectivement la question se pose de
savoir si la continuité et ou si elle va
s'il va continuer géopolitique ou si
elle va Molière dans ses sanctions
contre l'Ukraine notamment parce que
l'Italie dépend pour 25% encore de son
gaz en Russie même si Mario Draghi a
essayé de diversifier cette
approvisionnement en gaz et bien il est
toujours il est toujours encore très
dirigé vers la Russie donc ça aussi
c'est une grande inquiétude de l'Union
européenne voilà on verra à l'oeuvre il
y aura pas de gouvernement avant au
moins un mois puisque ça sera plutôt fin
octobre que ce gouvernement devrait être
constitué que Sergio matarella le
Président il doit d'abord la nommer donc
tout ça va prendre quelques semaines
d'ici là bien sûr on va en reparler et
on en reparlera lui aussi le jour J
merci Caroline de Camaret Merci à VOUS
John Luca pasarelli d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de Bologne merci Michela
Marzano d'avoir été avec nous merci
Béatrice Giblin et puis Merci à VOUS
Carlo Alberto à brouza merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi pour rester avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]